this is a production of cornell
university
i wanted to thank you all so much for
the invitation this is a real honor for
me
uh and i wish that i was in person but
with the code restrictions and
everything like that we couldn't make it
uh due to usda restrictions but
and i'm a little bit under the weather
today i have a cold i don't have coven
but i'm working from home and i hope i
can deliver this and my voice doesn't
give out
but again my my uh title my uh slides uh
are going to just be talking about
domestication breeding
genetics in in cranberry and just a real
honor to be here and i hope next time is
in person
so my slides are a little bit slow i
don't know why but hopefully we can get
through them
i am part of the usda as pro so some of
you know i'm a research geneticist i'm
stationed at the university of
wisconsin-madison and we have
three units i belong to the vegetable
crop research unit but we also have the
cereal crops research units and we also
have the usda forage research center and
the vcru we work in multiple crops
including carrot
and garlic and onions and
cucurbits
potatoes and of course cranberries
we are again embedded in the department
of horror culture where we function
you know as a you know somewhat as a
faculty we we help train students we you
know give some seminars we may help with
classes uh here and there and we of
course do
do the research
and this is an older picture of the
department but you know maybe some of
you recognize some of the people here
some of them are gone some of them are
still here the picture is more intended
to show
the number of faculty in the department
and then the number of scientists
that are part of the usda
uh in the arrows
you know we are about half of the
department
in terms of
numbers
we have a few that retire this year but
we're hoping to replace them so mike
havey
spooner and janski they all retire this
year or
maybe
last year
that end of the year so we're hoping to
recruit some new people and but this
this is a really nice department to be
in and we have a strong presence of the
usda scientists we also
my lab is called the cranberry genetics
and genomics lab and this is a picture
of a zoom meeting that we had not too
long ago
where we can still we can still meet in
person so you know we've been conducting
a lot of our meetings and and efforts
online and in person whenever possible
uh i typically have you know helped
train four to six graduate students and
i have a number
of grad undergrads that help uh those
grad students and you know uh lately i
haven't had a postdoc but you know we
have had many postdocs come through the
lab uh in the interns and invited
scientists that come to our lab and so
it's always this is probably one of my
favorite parts of this job is to be able
to interact with students
and here's my outline i'm not going to
go through it but you know i have a lot
of slides a lot of them are very quick
just to show you uh like a picture a
visual of what i'm trying to tell you so
here's the background
you know cranberries are a part of their
kc family where we have about a hundred
genera three thousand
these these are plants that are although
they like to be and and they can they
can survive underwater they're not
actually
um
aquatic plants they like actually
well-drained acidic soils and you know
species that are related to cranberry
that are interesting to me because i
work in cranberry
are lingonberry and blueberry
more recently i had a trip to hawaii and
i encountered a vaccinium called
vaccinium
which is
basically a type of it looks pretty much
like a cranberry but it grows in hawaii
so you know we're always looking for new
species that we can look into and maybe
make crosses rhododendrons and asylus
are other species that are closer
related but cranberries are
they live in a very unique environment
uh
in the wild so you can see here there's
a layer of sphagnum moss and then
there's like
you know you know plants that are
carnivorous plants around it there you
can see a runner here uh basically a
cranberry this is vaccinium oxicocus
which is not the
cultivated cranberry but but these are
plants that are
adapted to acidic environments very low
nutrient environments so here's here are
some pitcher plants
surrounding some cranberries and the
wild sometimes cranberries don't produce
fruit
and they're more clonal so cranberries
can reproduce clonally
by the runners and then
a lot of the plant is tend to be a lot
of the wild stands tend to be clonal
because one genotype takes over and then
there's a little bit of fruit you can
see on the top of this picture here
i'm gonna see if i can get my cursor on
them you can see there's a fruit there
and there
but overall you know pruning is not like
you know it's not present in all of the
populations in the wild so this is one
of the things that when we go to while
populations we look for
is which gives fruit and which don't
so again we have two species the
cultivated species is vaccine
microcarbon is shown in red here in dark
red in lines is mostly
uh a species that lives in the eastern
united states and the eastern north
america
you know from minnesota all the way to
massachusetts and up north to canada and
uh you know originally when cranberry
was cold
started to get cultivated people
selected
native or wild plants from there and
then they planted them then vaccinium
oxycoccus is a
close relative
that
sometimes is diploid or tetraploid
and that's more widely distributed
across north america
uh and we're trying to see where we can
use it for crosses and things but this
species the tetragonals don't cross well
and the diploids will cross readily but
the
one of the issues is the fruit is way
smaller and the plant itself is more
like a miniature version of microcarbon
uh
you know
phenotypically the plants can be easily
differentiated one is basically small
and the other one is large and
genetically you can see that we have
used multiple types of markers like ssrs
and snips
and the differentiation is very clear at
the genetic level
here's a picture oxycocases in red and
microcarbon is in blue
and then we also have tried to go out
all over the country and look for wild
plants we have discovered some
populations of macrocarbon in the west
and the far west of the united states
which was never reported before
and we're also looking at the genetic
diversity because of clonality sometimes
people used to say that cranberries
don't have any diversity but we we've
shown that that's not true there's a lot
of diversity there's a lot of structure
because of that clonality and then uh
we also are looking for populations that
produce fruit which is kind of a rare
it's more of a on the rare side to have
fruit
not all wild populations produce produce
fruit and not every year particularly
so we've done kind of a survey of the
united states and tried to collect
materials and this is how we built our
collection we collaborated with some
native american tribes sometimes and
trying to collect
these materials
and
you know of course native americans knew
about cranberries even before the
the settlers moved in and really liked
cranberries so
cranberries are a natural
food for the native american people they
used it as a preservative they
because of the high content of acids
like benzoic acid acid they would mix it
with meats and different different
grains and things that they had and they
created
basically what i call the first
power bar if you will so it's a way to
preserve food over the winter they use
it as medicine as fabric dye and for
them as a sacred
uh sacred fruit
i've had a chance to have some
connections with native american people
and the state here particularly the
menominee
just talking to an elder the fruit
they call it piakaman and i'm i'm sorry
if i'm not pronouncing it correctly but
you know just listening to him
uh you know that's how he pronounced it
and you know many other tribes and the
north american knew about the
cranberries and the benefits of eating
and
uh cranberries and and gathering them
and of course when the settlers came in
they came across the berries and then
they call them cranberries
and then that that word became cranberry
later on and of course in spanish we
call we call cranberry sarandano rojo
which is uh you know if it's blueberry
which is closely related we would call
that aranda no azul
so blue and ren
but
you know just uh you know having a
chance to maybe meet with some of this
native american tribes i've been trying
to figure out ways to connect with them
and collect fruit in the reservations
and i had a chance to go to the
menominee reservation and work with the
college of the menominee nation
and you know we helped develop a formal
and informal science education
curriculum that
just basically values and infuses
indigenous contributions to the
scientific knowledge that the
the unit was an old school unit
that we call that they called all my
relatives and it just captures the
experience of the indigenous
uh people in this particular case the
menominee and and into the science
learning process and all this was in the
context of the
uh menomonee forest which is one of the
largest
preservations or native american
preservations
in wisconsin and maybe even in the
united states and it was a very nice way
to connect you know they informed us
where there's
you know populations and you know our
studies and trying to find wild
populations we use some of their ideas
and everything we didn't get to collect
in the menomonee
preservation yet and so that's one of
the things that i'm working on trying to
you know see if we can get in there and
and find maybe some unique
genotypes
but again here's a photo of a cranberry
flower you can see
the resemblance with a crane and that's
why it was originally named cranberry
and then again they just dropped the e
and became cranberry
for production
i have that to say that you know
wisconsin of course is a very important
state in production we produce about 60
of all cranberries in the country
massachusetts coming second
this is one of the reasons i was hired
to be stationed in wisconsin because of
the strong presence of cranberry growing
in the state
you know we produce
um
[Music]
of all the acres and all the production
95 of the cranberries are processed um
you know only about five percent is
consumed fresh
and the main
um uses usage as juice and then dried
and dried is becoming like the more the
most important product now because a lot
of people like it you know in cereals
and in different
you know products that can be
incorporated so that's why dried is
probably the most
valuable product that we have in
cranberries
and of course you know it was
it's somewhat a recent
um
[Music]
uh
you know usage that people have been
interested in cranberries uh you know uh
that it has been popular i guess it has
been
available for a while but you know i i
myself didn't see it you know all the
time growing up
and i guess you know people weren't are
interested in the
phytochemicals and the health benefits
that cranberry may bring
is they're full of vitamin c
fiber manganese
pigments and their
you know cranberries are linked to many
uh health
uh
positive effects
the growth habits is also very
interested in cranberries cranberries
are long-lived perennial
uh and they tend to have a biennial
bearing although these
uh biennial bearing is somewhat changing
because breathing
we're breeding you know to not have this
so strong this biennial bearing effect
uh but you know here's here's a picture
of a cranberry branch that we call
runners so the the lower branch here
would be a runner and then the uprights
will be this this upright branches
coming out of a runner
and
the ones that
carry fruit that year will be called
reproductive uprights and the other ones
will be vegetative operates
so that's just a little terminology for
cranberry
for cranberries and here's the cycle of
cranberries i mean just you know
this the cycle is somewhat complicated
but just to say
that in in the winter cameras are
dormant in the spring
they they wake up and they start growing
and then by june we have flowering and
then around july we have butt set for
next year
so if uh if this is an uh cultivar that
is not so much affected by biennial
bearing it might be setting
a bud for next year and then we have
fruiting and then we have maturity and
we have harvest around october you know
i harvest around september but a lot of
growers harvest in october and maybe
even into november
so we just finished
harvesting
uh here's a flower uh here's the bud
that basically starts growing in the
spring and then that produces a flower
uh of course this is a field full of
flowers and then of course we're be
pollinated
here's an example of some runners
you can see those long branches they
basically allow the cranberry to
colonize ground
cranberries are kind of low to the
ground somewhat low to the ground and so
these runners allow the
the
vine to spread and here's an upright so
you can see you can still see soil in
this uh planting
but the plant is already
producing fruit which sometimes can be
disadvantageous because then those fruit
may fall and then
seed may germinate and contaminate the
planting
so that leads me to propagation
essentially a cranberry cultivar is one
genotype and that genotype gets
propagated massively and then acres and
acres are planted from that one genotype
so you can do it uh you know
commercially like in this this photo
and then take those blocks out to the
field
uh and then you know they use different
equipment you know and different
techniques to plant but this is just you
know a tractor that sits a bunch of
people in the back and then the tractor
makes the
the borrows where the people are putting
in the plugs and when the field is
finally planted you can see
uh basically lines of you know genotype
the same genotype basically just planted
at a certain distance and then as those
plants grow the runners will basically
take over the land and just colonize the
whole planting but essentially you see
the height there might be the height of
the planting i mean like i would say one
to two maybe you know things that are
very old can be like three feet deep but
in general you know we stay around one
to two feet deep
uh so here's another planting recently
planted and that's already kind of
spreading a little bit but eventually
that would become a carpet
and then it will be full of vine
cranberry buying
and another way to propagate this mowing
so an established planting will be mode
and that mode would be collected into
bells and those bells will be just
spread over a new field
and then you know they use different
equipment to kind of make contact
between the vine the woody plant
material
and the sand or the
you know whatever soil it is
then then they might even spread soil on
top of the vine so in this case sanding
they call that sanding and that will
then they will put water on it and that
will allow the propagule to basically
come back and just colonize the news the
new planting
so
this is because cranberry plantings are
clonal then it's very important to have
you know the appropriate material
license propagators are very popular
you know less and less people are doing
mowing although you know
mowing is still popular but you know i
think you know many people are starting
to use more and more propagators and
then also genetic
genetic testing for
for uh especially if they are doing
mowing they're doing more genetic
testing
uh on about the harvest
uh so here's a planting
that you know looks more mature with
with the vine already covering the
ground these these some of these are
plots that are breeding plots so you can
see spaces in between the plots
but you know when the
the plants are
originally planted you can still see
sand through this like what you see here
but you know they start flowering
and fruiting somewhat quickly
uh you know by the third year you might
already have or maybe fourth year you
may have fruit already growing and so
you have to manage for fruit so that
that fruit doesn't land in the
in the fresh sand and then maybe
germinate seed but when the
the planting is mature you you should
you shouldn't see
uh the ground and like this one is a
little bit more mature planting ready to
harvest
and the way that people have harvested
before is just using any labor available
in the old days you know a lot of native
american
people would work in the cranberry
marshes and harvest help harvest along
with you know women children and anybody
that was available here's a great
picture that i love about the harvest in
1880
just shows families going out there and
this particular photo is more of a wild
stand so people would go to a wild place
kind of clean it up
keep the grasses away keep some of the
trees away and just kind of clean it up
and again some of this wild stands not
all flower and fruit
so you know so people would go and find
the ones that were more productive while
stands and then harvest from those so
there's a here's a little girl carrying
a tool
so that would be
the kind of tool that would be used for
hand harvesting and this at this time in
this photo she was probably doing
harvesting in dry
cranberries and she has a little bucket
where she's putting the cranberries in
and then later on they kept using the
same kind of tool but they decided
somebody had the idea that let's put
water on the plant thing because
cranberries are tolerant to water to
flooding
so then you can put water around them
and that allows the
this type of equipment this type of tool
to be more
more easily
maneuver
in trying to collect the cranberries you
can see
that in this picture here
so here's another picture of water aided
harvesting using like hand tool
and of course that is because you know
cranberries float when you put water on
it if you put enough water the
cranberries will kind of come to the top
so you can skim
any kind of tool
you know close to the surface of the
water and then that will allow the
cranberries to be kind of removed
gently without destroying the vine
and so that will protect your harvest
for next year
and so you know water harvesting you
really changed the caribbean industry
around the 1950s and that became
like the engineering it's like a feat of
engineering if you will there's all
kinds of ditches waters moving right and
left north and south
and all the water has to come back
and uh
there's not enough water to flood all of
the marsh at one point so you know have
you know people have to
uh you know flooded by bed and you know
using different strategies to do it in
sections
and so here is a mechanical harvester in
the 1940s
uh this was a hand
pushed more uh basically harvester
uh here's an example of a tractor in the
1950s when this became more popular
you know people started actually
adapting tractors and everybody makes
their own
machine so here's another guy with a
different type of machine but it's also
uh you know type of tractor gas powered
and here's another one
here's one last one
and then more recently you know we have
big companies making big machines to
actually make this easier you know for
some reason this type of machine that
has those
those uh basically long needles if you
will that allows the vine
to be moved but it causes less damage
that is always one of the things that
we're looking during harvest is we don't
want to damage the
cranberries but the cranberries are
pretty resilient they can they can take
a big tractor basically running over
them and they they're fine i can walk
through them and they can hold me i'm a
big guy
and they can hold me okay
after the harvest basically all the
cranberries are floating around
and they have to be basically corralled
if you will so we use a type of boom
that basically brings the cranberries
together
as the cranberries get moved together
they move towards a
basically a bridge or
you know uh
escalator that will bring them over to
the
to the truck
and then different cranberry growers use
different techniques some people use
water some people use an elevator some
people uh just basically
uh you know use whatever ingenuity a lot
of these machines are not
you know commercially available it's
just what people make in their own farm
so there's a lot of diversity on what
people are using to do this different
tasks
some people even clean the cranberries
before they go to the truck and some
don't so you can see here there's a
truck where the trash is being removed
and then the cranberries are being
dumped in a truck
and of course people get very
uh
you know
you know fancy with some of the harvest
and so here's a just a picture of the
state of wisconsin kind of drawn during
the harvest in a cranberry marsh
and here's a picture of our chancellor
and our
dean
and just enjoying a harvest day in
cranberry country
with the domestication
i i also have a few stories
but cranberries basically began
to be
grown
more of a cultivated setting around
1816. before that everybody just went
out to the field or the wild stand and
just collected berries
and the way that these uh first
plantings were made is that people went
to a wild place collected just a sod or
a piece of
cranberries with roots right from from
the wild and then planted them and
started basically taking care of them
and cultivating them but the cultivation
quickly spread in the u.s and by 1853 we
were already growing cranberries
cultivated
in 1853
um
and then
the u.s army and a lot of the armies
around the world started using
cranberries as a source of vitamin c and
so that increased the popularity of
cranberries and rapidly became an
industry
the original plantings
were basically selections from the wild
and people just went out and looked for
cranberries that looked bigger that were
more maybe more juicy
um
you know but i think the selection the
original selections
uh around the 1830s were probably just
related to fruit size precise and
and they were they were just uh and then
maybe the ability to you know those wild
stands that had fruit all the time
you know as i as i mentioned before
sometimes wild stands don't have fruit
um so here are some of the names of the
cultivars that were originally selected
from the wild and in all there was
about 132 wow selections documented
uh and the first reading program started
in 1929
uh here's a picture of the wisconsin
station that was part of that program
and that uh program
kind of ended
around the 1960s and produced seven
cultivars and one of those cultivars was
stevens which is the major cultivar
today
about 40 of the industry grows stevens
but this little figure here and timeline
kind of just shows the
cranberry only has had two breeding
cycles and basically one selection cycle
from the wild so between 1835 to 1960
all of the cranberry cultivars well were
wild selections so for 125 years we
didn't have
any breeding and then around 1929 to
1960 there were seven developed
cultivars and then from
2003 to the present there's now
maybe 10 more cultivars so we have
maybe
17 to 20
breaded cultivars and if you will 132
wild selections
so here's how red would which was the
first modern cranberry cultivar or the
this was developed in 2003 here in
wisconsin and this just this is just a
comparison between high red and stevens
just kind of showing that you know
higher red is as the name indicates just
more
accumulates more pigment
uh and here the cranberry breeders were
a very
very very few people my predecessor
brent mccown and eric selden are
shown here on the left
um
and then you have the gregoleski family
erin is ed and his dad they have been
doing breeding they have a private
company here in wisconsin and they
they're doing an amazing job doing some
reading
then of course nick vorsa uh who has
been my mentor for a few years now
uh and and great breeder and then
there's a picture of me there and the
newest breeder which is my counterpart
part in uh
in new jersey as uh jeff
and so that's that's a small group of
breeders but uh you know we work
together well
and here's a cranberry domestication fig
pic just uh you know figure just to show
an example of a wild selection
uh there on the top corner of the left
side and you can see this uh this wild
plant is just random but the selections
are
uh on the side of it there's four
selections there and just you know i
think the selection was mainly just for
fruit size just try to find something
that is productive in the wild all the
time and that is a little bigger fruit
and that was the pretty much the first
selection cycle
and then the 1960s
hybrids were released that basically
combined the most
productive wild plants and that had
bigger fruits and that gave rise to to a
little bit more productive plants that
would have bigger fruits and then in the
in this current cycle i think breeders
are working on color they're working on
fruit size
we're working on
basically just more production
and you know just more appealing looking
fruit
um again things that that cranberry
breeders are looking for that we're
looking for is improved color for
quality nutrition rebutting which is the
we're trying to reduce the effect of
biennial bearing yield is always
important
taste early maturing cold tolerance and
pet pest disease although here in
wisconsin we're doing less of
of these last two in in in the east
coast they're doing a little more more
of these two
uh last two traits
uh and just now i'm gonna get into you
know some of the research in my lab
but just to say that i was hired in 2010
at the end of 2010 so in the beginning
of 2011 is when i started trying to
develop some molecular resources as the
first thing that i tried to do
and i went to i remember going to the
gene bank and uh finding that there were
only
a few sequences for vaccinium and for
cranberry at the time i think there were
only 15 sequences so i was like trying
to develop some markers
and i said well i don't have a lot of
choices you know there were no
no sequences there that i could use to
develop any type of markers so i was
beginning to think what what type of
markers should i develop and at the time
you know next generation sequencing
became really possible for you know
crops like cranberry that are
you know somewhat minor crops and you
know uh with a little bit less funding
so we did some 454 we did some illumina
and so based on that we
started really accumulating very quickly
a lot of sequence data
that we could use and the first thing we
did is we assembled the organelle
genomes and published those
and then after that we started
developing some ssr markers just from
uh from a uh
basically uh
um
a search that we then it with using the
the 454 sequence data and the lumina
data and we did kind of an silico
approach to
to discover ssrs and test them kind of
in the computer before we actually
like uh you know started ordering a lot
of primers because we didn't have so
much money to to start ordering a bunch
of primers and so we developed our first
map
uh you know
uh in cranberries around 2013 with a
hundred markers
then later
uh we added markers to this and then it
became like seven like
almost 600 markers and all these
populations were developed by nick warsa
at the time one of the problems that i
had is that i had no
no material no
no populations it takes you know you
know three to five six years to develop
a population and planting it
a a number of more of years so i i kind
of partnered with nick warsa and when
jim paula shock and rutgers and we
started doing things together
so all these maps are in collaboration
with them
um here is a third
map basically that we did in 2016. by
the way i'm gonna go back just to show
you that this is 2013
this is 2015.
this is 2016 and so here we have now
access to to to development of snips
markers
uh that they basically we did by the
genotype and by sequencing approach in
fact we
developed these markers with the use of
uh cornell at the time
and uh we had a kind of a a
draft a very low
i would say
lower quality draft of the carbon genome
and based on that we were able to use
this gps technique and just you know get
a snips and add that to the ssrs that we
had and then later
we added other populations so we had in
this case three populations and these
are populations that we're trying to
study
ma traits also but uh you know
and
we were hoping to do qtl markers uh
analysis with them
uh but we were able to develop
a composite map out of three populations
that were actually studying for trades
also
so here this is in 2017
and this is kind of where we are right
now trying to use this maps and this
this technology that we've been
developing now to actually add trades
and just really start understanding the
genetic structure of
of the criminal genome in terms of
traits and everything else so
all the things that we have been able to
do thanks to this technology is to
compare ourselves and use information
from other crops so we've done some
comparative genomics with kiwi fruit
with grape
you know we we haven't really
used a lot of this information you know
for for anything just to say well you
know where we are in terms of other
other crops but we're working more
closely with blueberry blueberry is very
close to us i will show you some
pictures of that in a minute here
but uh you know just going back to a
little bit of the work that we did with
ssrs is that you know we did we we did
um develop some about 700 ssrs that have
been very useful in my program
and you know so here's just a little bit
of what we do with them we
are very interested in finding out
all of these wild plants that were
originally selected so what are they
what is their genotype and how are they
used in crosses
uh that produce the first cycle and the
second cycle of primary breeding a lot
of these
things are noted in different
books in historical material but we
wanted to corroborate some of these
things so here's an example of a cross
that is very important
and
so hi stevens was crossed with ben lear
bentley is a wild selection and stevens
is a first generation hybrid and that
got crossed to high red so
you know we we actually can show that
that is true in some cases we've
discovered that the crosses that that
the breeders made were not exactly the
way they
they intended or they thought and so we
corrected that where we can and we're
just doing a database of
you know basically
the genotypes and parentage and you know
i have a new paper that is going to come
out with the genotype of like i believe
it's over 20 cultivars that are
interesting and useful in crimea
breeding
you know and then again you know we can
we can differentiate
with simple ssrs we can differentiate
and identify cultivars and that's one of
the things that we
concentrated a lot is to try to
preserve a lot of these materials and go
find them and put them in collections
and just you know make sure that people
are growing what they think they're
growing
and then you know off of this is also to
help growers
uh test their fields again since
everything is supposed to be a chrono
planting in this particular case this is
a march where everything was supposed to
be stevens
and then the grower was having some
problems
in some some beds and and they told me
why don't we just do a like mars wide
study where we collect samples
and and then figure out if there are any
differences in bad
uh genetic composition and so we did
find some of the bets that that are
that the growers having problems like
this one here on the top you can see
all the yellow
uh
color dots are
basically not the correct genotype and
all of the red is supposed to be
uh the the stevens genotype which is the
one that they were intended to grow so
we do this all the time
we've tested
over 500 growers samples here in our
state
we test you know 20 to 30 to 40 grower
samples every year i mean i mean
individual
growers that send the samples and you
know we do you know anywhere from from
24 to 100 samples per grower depending
on what the problem they're having and
we try to help them
clean their operation if you will some
make decisions on
on renovation
and some make decisions on cultural
practices
and then again the ssrs have been useful
to us to
study vaccinium
in particular crosses with the closest
relative of cranberries vaccine and
oxycocas then you know women trying to
cross with lincoln berry with corn
blossom and different species
we do have some crosses
between the cranberries and so you know
our initial efforts have been
uh applying ssrs and now we're applying
snips and we're actually trying to map
some of these process segregate widely
and it's very interesting just to see
the segregation on on some of these
causes because the plants are so
different
uh and then you know one thing that we
that was very encouraging because i'm
the in the beginning i wasn't sure
if i should pursue some of the blueberry
cranberry crossing
breeding uh but then we did that we used
the ssrs and we demonstrated that
cranberry and blueberry have
basically a lot of symphony the
chromosomes align perfectly there is no
major translocations or mutations that
we can find
and
more recently in 2021
we finished our cranberry genome this is
again
uh so just just a little bit ago
the
cranberry genome using pac bio
we
had the 12 chromosomes
and most of the genome was assembled and
there we still have a few gaps we're
still looking to develop the genome and
we also developed a genome for the
closest wild relative of cranberry and
diploid
basically accession from the oxy caucus
that we call microcarbon
and we're hoping now to get together
with back cap and with bringing insight
and different people that will help us
create more genomes we have plans to
create a cranberry pan genome based on
10 different genomes
so that's going to be coming up pretty
soon here and also a genotyping platform
that is going to have 21 000 genes or 20
000 genes plus
another platform that is going to be
developed with brilliant insight that
has 3 000 and now we're hoping to really
be able to have
a really
deep
coverage and and excellent marker
density for any study that we want to do
again
and based on this genome we also were
able to show again that the blueberry
genome and the cranberry genome are very
very satanic
so there's there's uh you know here you
can see the chromosomes of crown very
different colors
and we're showing the 12 and then the
tetraploid blueberry chromosomes you can
kind of see the color that corresponds
to what cranberry chromosome so so
that's very encouraging and that kind of
supports some of the research that i've
been doing in terms of breeding
terms of phenotyping trait data
we've been trying to follow the
traditional measurements and add
you know measurements so when i came
here people told me what traits that you
measure
and i've been doing that plus creating
new traits and part of the work that
we're doing in terms of trait
measurement is related to the back cap
project
uh massimo yorito in north carolina as
our team are
basically our pi our leader and i of
course i worked with warza and paula
shock and maya tucca and different many
different people on this project
but we're looking for traits that are
important for
uh fruit
for dried fruit so you know things like
color shape fleshiness and firmness are
really the most important traits for
this type of product
we have collected over 70 fruit quality
traits
some of them
are
related to external appearance internal
structure and firmness which we can
measure many many different ways
um but just to show the clarity external
appearance the way that we do it is in
around 2016 we started developing this
basically way to just take a picture
and
see if we could just uh you know
look at this basically from a picture
standpoint
organize the berries put a little
basically stand there on the sides and
then basically take a picture with a
very journali
little
picture stand if you will that we that
we came up with one of my students had a
little bit of engineering
uh background so he he built this from
from our lab from just pieces of scrap
you know wood that we had and everything
and so you know we started like you know
making a little r coat
that would recognize the fruits and
compare them to a standard and then
basically very easily tell
simple things like the the perimeter the
length the width
and and then another student came around
and said well maybe we could use the
pixels to like look at how dark the
fruit is whether it's light or dark and
so then we did kind of a fruit color
analysis we published this
i believe maybe in 2017 or you know
around that time
and you know essentially it's a
an art code that just you know looks at
the photos and then it spits out a an
excel sheet with just different ways of
looking at
the
the fruit and you know
all these measurements are related to
food shape
size and color
and color variation i think is one of
the most interesting ones because in
cranberries we want to have all the
fruit to kind of be color
and not
uh
basically
blushy
so internal structure we kind of took
the same approach
we uh we do we were doing a kind of a
an outreach event where students little
kids would come over and cut cranberries
and then
stop
use the cranberry to use as a stamp and
it was like a very
uh you know colorful experiment we would
just like use different colors and
and
and then one day we said why don't we
use this to actually see if we can
measure the internal structure of
cranberry we noticed that
that was back in 2011 when we started
doing that outreach event and then we
said uh we noticed that there was very
different inside of the cranberries and
so we started figuring out how to
measure these stamps
and we created another little software
that
measures the cranberries and it kind of
um creates
a way of kind of rotating the image and
measuring the inside of the cranberry
creating uh you know about 10 parameters
related to the flesh inside and or the
absence of flesh inside of the cranberry
and we're using that now to analyze the
fruit in the cranberry
backup project
for fruit firmness we've tried many
different things
uh among them the double compression
which tends to be the best test for us
uh you know using different strains
different speeds you know double and
single different things uh you know but
the main idea is that when you have you
press a cranberry you know there's a
force required to press that cranberry a
certain percentage of the size and so
based on that you know we're developing
different ways of looking at the data
you can do a
first compression and a second
compression and compare the peaks and
many many different things that
they're somewhat frankly out of my uh
expertise but you know we're consulted
with food science people that are
helping us decide what are the best
techniques all the things that we've
tried is puncture
and then the blade
and then the kramer test
and we're working
uh with all of those traits and see
which ones can help us determine the
firmness
we also are moving towards more of a
sharp knife
and those those are the work that we're
going to do
uh later but in general just to say that
cranberries can be differentiated
different genotypes with different
properties that growers tell us this is
a firmer this is not so firm
we can differentiate them using this
firmness techniques and we also store
the fruit and then we pull it out and
then we can see the decay of the fruit
using these techniques so we're we're
happy with where we're getting we're
trying to
use this data for uh further qtl mapping
and other studies
in terms of yield
we are collecting yield data in terms of
like upright
yield so you can see you can take an
upright and count how many fluids are
there and the weight
uh
and then we're also you're using the
plot yield method so basically we have a
square and we collect all the from that
square one of the problems with this
method is that sometimes you can get
different results the error can be high
sometimes so we're trying to figure out
how to
change um
how to look at the plot data i think
this is one of the biggest challenges
and the cranberry
uh trade data is the collection of
yields so we've experimented with images
we're experimenting with drones with
sensor technology and the ideas like may
one day
this is luis uh
uh
diaz garcia one of my students as soon
as some of you may know
and we're
we're always thinking about how to use
different technologies so that we can be
drinking coffee while we collect data
but you know we're somewhat far away
from that yet
uh there are some advances we used
photos uh you know microwaves is i'm
sorry is that a question um we've got
only only got about two or three minutes
left did you want to do some um uh
questions or are you people
keep going either way i ha i have like
maybe a few more slides left but you
know we can leave it here if you want
you know basically trade data i was
going to cover something on qtl mapping
you know we have a ton of qto's
developed maps
some candidate genes
you know a ton of data that we have
collected in populations breeding
you know a little bit on the faces of
breeding
uh let's see
let me get to the last part here i just
want to show you one more picture
a little bit on the uh you know harvest
field plant things
uh
and one of the most exciting things is
our blueberry crosses
so we have some hybrids with blueberry
and we have some fruit
uh that is coming out of the blueberry
cranberry hybrid so with that you know i
can stop and just take some questions if
you i apologize i i thought i had a
little bit of more time
okay we've got one question from the
chat from uh
justine can you see that can you can you
see the chat yes
okay great
so is there any path towards improving
fruit set through breeding
uh five to seven flowers for
form only one to two fruit or at least
is in the case of the massachusetts
box how can that be improved yeah so
that's one of the things that i was
showing there i mean that's why we're
collecting fruit
upright data so you know i'm collecting
not only the
the overall square footage
you know
yield but we're also looking at the
upright level and so we're counting
things like how many aborted fruit how
many
you know uh how many flowers and then
what what was the fate of those flowers
uh
throughout the the the whole cycle and
so we're really looking at that and you
know i i think that there is something
to that there is there are genotypes
that have more energy to to give to
fruit and that's actually
probably one of the ways that calvary
breathing is is going that way
uh right now is just we're looking at
uprights themselves as the unit of
selection
okay i'm afraid we're about out of time
um uh dr zalapa i really appreciate your
time here and um
uh maybe we could leave uh uh your your
um uh uh
email email address in the chat or
something for folks in case they want to
talk to you about anything else that be
okay
yes great okay well thank you very much
thank you
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu